everything in the legislation that's
written in family law throughout most of
the Western countries so not just Canada
but many states in the U.S and the UK
and Australia and stuff like that
they're mostly written to enrich and
protect women which would have made
sense 30 40 years ago when deadbeat dads
were not you know taking care of their
kids but they changed the laws in in
such a way that you're basically treated
as an ATM if you're a man they extract
resources from you
they uh criminalize you you know in the
sense where fathers are not appreciated
uh they're disparaged they're looked
down upon they're not respected the same
way that moms are and they essentially
move his resources to her and they do it
in such a way that allows her to control
the untying of the knot which generally
means control comes with with authority
and power over the family and over the
kids which they generally give to women
eight out of 10 times still
and he's often left in a position where
he's bankrupt destitute broke living in
his parents basement watching his wealth
transfer over to his ex while she
alienates him from his own kids now I
didn't personally have that experience I
didn't have a great experience but my
experience was such that I started to
read case law between couples getting
divorced when I was going through my own
divorce because I had to square away in
my head what I was up against because
I'm very I'm a very strategic player in
life like I play chess when I was a kid
for for years so
um I approach a lot of things in life
from a strategic perspective so I wanted
to learn as much as I could about
divorce which I did and again that was
my second moment because I thought well
I thought it would have been easy but
it's not it's very difficult and most
men get wrecked at the end of it and
it's not great for kids either I mean
the real losers in this
um some would argue are the fathers but
I think the real losers end up being the
kids because they end up getting they
don't understand the effect that that
being raised by a single mom has until
they become adults and they realize that
most single mother households are
essentially beta factories like that's
one of the things that softens and
weakens males is 43 of children today
are being raised in single parent
households which is either by choice
because you know moms just get pregnant
and they get Knocked Up by a loser and
he runs off or you know they end up
getting you know uh
divorced and they end up taking uh you
know the resources from the father but
either way it's it's either by no choice
or by choice you know choices around but
they but they still are in control of
raising the kids eighty percent of the
time and they don't do a very good job
of it the vast majority of teenage
pregnancies crappy marks in school
runaways gang activity suicide attempts
um you know you can go right down the
list
um the vast majority of the incarcerated
today in jail has come from a
single-parent household you know from a
single mom so they don't do a very good
job at it so that's so that's part of
the beta Factory
um you know issue that comes up with
softening mail so the whole divorce
process for me was a big red pilling
moment so that was number two the third
one was after I got divorced
um so I was married for a few years I
was you know engaged and and dating my
ex-wife you know for quite a while
um and then I went back into the dating
pool I don't know 2013 or so I guess
um and that's where I I started mostly
dating women around my age or a little
bit younger so I think it was 38 39 at
the time and I got involved like I was
dating a bunch of women having a good
time you know you're talking to them and
a lot of them were you know for the most
most part train wrecks they weren't in
very good shape they weren't very
attractive I've always taken very good
care of myself as far as what I eat and
exercise so I came across this one gal
who was very fit
she had the typical post-divorce breast
augmentation you know so she looked hot
a lot of people would would have
commented at the time when I was dating
her like she looks like Jennifer Aniston
so she was that caliber of
attractiveness right so if you're a fan
of friends you know what I'm talking
about but I dealt with her for about
three years and she had two kids in tow
from her own uh separation slash divorce
and I invested into a relationship with
her and kids that weren't mine and these
ego Investments never paid off you know
I got a lot of
push back a lot of disrespect I
discovered that you have responsibility
as a parent to somebody else's kid but
you don't have any Authority and
as a father you know you generally have
responsibility to your own kid with
authority now the authority part's been
stripped is slowly been Stripped Away
but the
but the deal that you get when you sign
up for a single mom sucks because you
end up essentially cuckolding yourself
which if you don't know what that means
you're essentially choosing to raise
another man's seat when you get involved
with a single mom because they're
generally not looking for love they're
looking for help yeah you know there's
this notion that they're looking for
love and that they want to another stab
at it they want another you know go at
love maybe the grass is green or
somewhere else maybe they'll find a
better man sort of thing and that might
be the initial push for it but but
they're really not looking for love
they're generally looking for help in
life so
I did that ego investment spent three
years with them traveled paid for you
know paid for certain things you know
here and there and at the end of it I
ended up getting you know betrayed
um she ended up cheating on me a couple
times and um
the the whole notion of putting time
effort and resources into somebody else
and their kids is just such a bad idea
and I didn't know how bad of an idea it
was until I went through it so all of
these things that I experienced
um the wisdom comes from the pain you
know the wisdom comes from the bad
choices and I really think that's why
younger people today should really pay
attention to older guys that have lived
life and have those experiences these
these 20 something year old gurus that
are holding out to the public that
they're Experts of making money or love
or women or whatever they're mostly a
bunch of idiots lying and they're either
lying or they don't know what they're
talking about so
I think a lot of guys get LED astray and
don't get the best information because
again you know the wisdom that I have
has come from the experience with the
choices that I made in business in
marriage and dating and love and all
that sort of stuff and the truth of the
matter is is those three things back to
back were really what unplugged me from
you know society's comforting lies right
um just do the right thing and get
involved with a single mom and be the
man that steps up because the other guy
was a loser because that's a story that
you hear from these moms all the time
he's a beta he was a competent he
couldn't hold a job down he was a loser
he didn't know how to change a light
bulb really but he was good enough when
you said I do when you guys got engaged
and married when you felt baby rabies
and wanted to have children right right
there and that he was good enough then
but later on down the road he's not good
enough so there's all these Concepts
that you learn about life and society
and culture and women in business and
love and all that sort of stuff that at
some point you know you have to come to
the realization and acceptance if you
want to live life on your terms if you
want to live life as what I would call
an unplugged Alpha mm-hmm and I think
you've only gained that by going through
those experiences and that's why like
looking at anyone at younger who hasn't
gone through it is crazy so like for me
who's 27 who's approaching Those Years
whereby baby rabies becomes a thing and
if anyone doesn't know that as people
where a woman literally gets crazy to
have a child and once have a child and
that that has so much relevance to me
because a lot of my friends are a little
bit older and I've heard women
explicitly say yeah like I'm looking to
have children not looking to get married
I can find a partner I'm not going to
find to have children and all I think in
my head is like Jesus [__] Christ
like I said
any guy will do that's got financial
resources and has sufficient looking
genes for her to want to be impregnated
by him I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out